well you're an incredibly positive
person one of the most
like productive people i've ever had the
privilege of knowing
uh and i i do want to talk to you a
little bit about like the yankees cap
you've got on like the
[Laughter]
your new york roots uh because when i
refer to fubu i remember the first time
i uh
got exposed to fubu was during that gap
commercial with little cool j
where he was just like four hours by us
and then i was so confused
even and that day because i was like
wait a minute did that guy just like
advertise another clothing brand while
he was
uh in a video for the gap
there were a lot of people that were
extremely confused when that happened
you know so so the story goes that ll
you know did put he wore a baseball cap
and he put for us by us on the low
in the gap ad and um uh because he was
frustrated
he felt the the gap wasn't really taking
you know they didn't they didn't respect
hip-hop they didn't respect him they
just wanted to
hire him to do this commercial um and
you know i think this reflects kind of
what we're seeing going on where
we talk about diversity and inclusion
because the gap
ended up spending 30 million dollars
airing that ad and i remember us in the
office looking at this going
at first i mean my mouth just dropped
the first week the second week
my mouth was still dropped but by by the
three and a half weeks in i was like
these idiots don't know what they did
what's happening because
they didn't have anybody to represent
the culture whether of color or whether
of music orientation
in the company so if you look at you
look at sometimes how
diversity and inclusion is probably
probably smart
you know to have a little bit of other
opinions because think about it they
spent 30 million dollars airing fubu ads
now i do have to give it up to the gap
you know what they did after that they
did their analytics right
uh and they realized that the target hit
market they were trying to hit increase
300 percent
because the kids thought they can get
fubu at the gap
they go out and rerun the ad and i got
to tell you they were brilliant for
doing that and i'm super happy that they
did that as well
that's an incredible story so that was
uh in the
early 90s when you guys were still
coming up and one of the stories that
you told me and that i got from your
book uh was
your first business was driving a van
across uh queens i think it was
where you would just stop and people
would get on and how much
money would they give you to get on the
van a dollar dollar each
so in new york they we call them uh
you can either call them gypsy cabs or
what they call them dollar dollar
vans and they're they're heavily in
brooklyn and queens
where we go up and down the bus route um
and people hop on and hop off and give
you a dollar
um and you know it was it was my
business for a long period of time but i
worked for about four years doing that
and then i was just drained because even
though i'm making 300 a day i was
i was grossing 300 a day i was probably
netting 15
a day by the time i paid for all my um
my beat up van pay for the gas and by
the way it's not legal if you don't have
uh taxi and limousine commission
issued plates so i get one ticket from
the department of transportation for
picking up in a bus stop
that was twenty five hundred dollars so
uh
that was uh that was a lesson i learned
about the difference of grossing and
netting
and um and how you should have
all the right things in place to run a
business because if you don't
you can you can really hurt yourself
so you went from driving back and forth
and during that time
i think you were starting to dabble in a
tire is that right like
what ski hats were some of your first
products yeah it was you know
it was my um my my couple of hats that i
sold
on um you know uh you know on the corner
and then i would go and buy
shirts and stuff with just characters on
it and then i would fill my van filled
with because i'll take the seats out of
the van
and then i'd fill it filled with super
soakers and during
the greek fest or picnic i go down to
jones beach and sell the super soakers
to all the kids so
i was always trying to find a way to to
make a couple of bucks
well fubu ended up being this incredible
leap of faith for your family your mom i
think she mortgaged the house to get you
the startup capital after she saw that
the business had potential
what a freaking family
you know love loyalty story that is
because i
i feel like a lot of others would you
know
wouldn't have had that kind of belief or
confidence
yeah mom had faith man um you know she
knew that i was working on the house as
well i was i was i was paying a lot of
the bills at some time you know her you
know she worked her jobs i did and
we collectively put together she
wouldn't necessarily give me the money
just out of
you know a leave of faith but i had
three hundred thousand dollars in orders
and i came home and i got turned down by
27 banks now
i rightfully so got turned down my 27
banks because i was not using the house
as collateral
and i didn't know how i didn't have
financial intelligence so
i i wasn't really filling out a loan
application the way that it should be
filled out
um but she did say this is all we have
this house so let's mortgage the house
and
uh then when you you know get the goods
out you put the money back in as soon as
you make the money
you put the money back in and she went
out and she got a hundred thousand
dollar loan on our house and i have no
idea because the house is worth 75
so to till today i haven't asked what
she did for the rest of the money but i
got to tell you
you know shout out to moms moms are the
ultimate entrepreneurs they figure it
out
well shoot man i'm not sure those banks
were right
not giving you that loan if you had 300
000 orders and that's something i would
love to see
change frankly like if there is an
entrepreneur like you coming up and
you have traction and are starting to
get momentum i mean someone has to
believe uh in your growth
i think and you know you see all these
frankly like tv commercials where the
banks are all like we're going to be a
partner in your growth
you know you'd like to see that that
play out for real
so this was around the time we're
talking about where fubu really took off
right
i started foot189 i closed it three
times from 89 to 92.
then i started again in 92 with my
buddies um
i would start getting public recognition
around 95
and like 96 97 is when i started i got
i got obviously my my bigger
manufacturing and distribution deal
and i got food watching the market and
that's when it started to really hit
around 97.98
well that that's incredible man and so
how big did the operation get
and when did you for example transition
out of your home to like an office to a
manufacturing facility and all the rest
of it because that must have been an
incredible time
you must have been still over your skis
in a lot of ways like figuring out
like you know i think it was the year 96
i had moved
three times i cuz my house i turned my
house into a factory and then i got my
deal
and i was no i was now stationed in the
empire state building
um you know the word was out the food
was making money so i was
i was fearful for my life uh you know at
in back in the neighborhood
so i couldn't return back to that house
and then i had moved uh i moved my
my wife uh who was my girlfriend the
time we just had a baby i moved her to
one place i moved
i moved to manhattan just for four
months so i can be right there at the
office
and um and then we finally we moved like
two more times we finally got our house
uh in long island sands point right
around 98.
i was in asia i was in uh europe and
uh i was traveling most of the time in
factories and stuff like that my life
was just a whirlwind and we were
right around 98 i think we started to we
we started to do around 350 uh 350
million dollars
annual sales and um it was it was a lot
going on uh you know
and you know in the apparel business
that's a great number but it's not the
biggest number i mean you think
you know people like nike are doing 30
billion a year you know and
ralph lauren probably three billion a
year but 350 million was uh
was was was a lot for me you know i was
i told you i was working a van i was
netting 15
a day so 350 million was was quite a
quite over my skis well
so you you built this household
name brand uh and then i think a lot of
these retailers are trying to get a
piece of the action
in different ways uh fubu is now
featured
in the smithsonian's national museum of
african american history and culture
which must be a real point of pride it's
like what the heck clothing brand makes
it into the smithsonian
and over time i mean that 350 million
peak mean you earned
over 6 billion in global sales over all
the years that that fubu was in
operation
uh but i do have the sense that you know
like you were learning as you were going
like what are like the giant lessons you
took
from from that the big takeaways were
that
there are good and bad people you know i
came from the streets and i
i i love this this to make apparel for
this new genre music and i was trying to
escape the clutches of drug dealers and
various other things i fell in the
streets but
uh the reality is when you have a lot of
money flowing through systems there's a
lot of bad people too they just don't
come with a gun they come with a pen
you know so be careful it also uh
lessons were trust your gut because
there may be a lot of things that look
good on paper or a person that looks
good in person but if your gut tells you
something and you can't necessarily
articulate
why you don't think you should do the
deal or why it's not in the best
interest
don't do it um you know and i i you know
it always ends up you know you need to
trust your gut
i think cockiness also comes into play
when you are
on top uh have a healthy paranoia and
the customers first
don't get too cocky don't don't uh don't
think that you know it all
and or you you can solve everything with
money you know um
so uh you know that came with it also
to understand the diversity in in your
company of the diversity of gender and
age and color and creed and beliefs and
and to make sure there are experts in
there i didn't know this but i didn't
realize that every for every 50 people
you probably need an hr person
so i became a shrink at the end of the
day in my company because i wanted
people to feel like there was an open
door policy and you can speak to me at
any time
but i can't be an expert in everything i
can't be an expert in the way to
communicate with other adults and
different genders and different
uh idealisms and you need people there
because your
your team is your that's your bread and
butter man that's your that's your
bloodline
and you made you need to make sure that
you are working just as hard and
listening to these people that work just
as hard for you
um to make them feel comfortable because
then if you do that they will they will
they will bust their butt for you
[Music]
you